hello I'm Zeynep Adar we welcome to the
magnificent concert hall here in
Stockholm where this year's Nobel Prize
winners receive their awards from the
king of Sweden the Nobel prizes are
amongst the most prestigious accolades
anywhere in the world and this is the
first time that this year's Nobel
laureates are appearing together on
television they're joined by their
friends and family who are taking part
in the celebrations and we also have an
invited audience of students from here
in Sweden will be hearing whether these
Nobel Prize winners believe that
scientists should be playing more of a
role in tackling the big problems of the
day
so here we are gentlemen and you are of
course all gentlemen Kesari Alice Munro
the Nobel laureate for Literature this
year couldn't join us but
congratulations to all of you what were
you all doing briefly when you heard the
news professor Randy Schekman
well I was deep asleep but my wife heard
the phone and she blurted out this is it
this is it I picked up the phone and I
heard a soft Swedish voice and although
I'm not a religious person I blurt out
oh my god and you knew that really was
it Francoise I'm Claire and I think you
were making your famous banana toast for
your grandchildren I see that the banana
toast is already something which is
internationally known the recipe was
asking me for the recipe for the banana
toast the problem was that may I was
there with my two daughters the events
of course could happen this year but you
know the clock went down from the number
thing went out he's in the ball number
close to zero and that nasty thing about
the Nobel Committee but you know you
will forever be remembered for the
banana toast when the news well your
your fellow laureate in physics
professor Peter Higgs you famously don't
have a mobile phone I do in fact but
only my family know the number ah that's
it so the Nobel Committee didn't so how
did you find out well I I found out when
I was walking back home I'd left home
late morning because although I wasn't
intending to avoid hearing the
announcement I was intending to avoid
the subsequent media attention so I made
sure that I was somewhere else for lunch
and I went to an art exhibition
afterwards and walked home about three
o'clock as I was walking
a former neighbor stopped their car
across the street came across to me and
said congratulations but my daughter's
just phoned from London and told me the
news about the award and I said what
award just a woman passerby gave you the
good news and a foreman a better there
you are professor Arya well show you you
are one of the Prize winners for
chemistry
what are you doing okay I took half
ambien to prevent reaction forward the
opposite news so I was sleeping very
deeply and then my wife woke me up and
again like Gandhi when I held the
Swedish accent and few people in the
background did you get back to sleep
afterwards no the news people already
canceled okay well I was sleeping
the phone rang I picked it up and I
immediately dropped it and it was dark
and there were two buttons to push you
know the green one and the red one and
when you get a call at that hour you
kind of know it's what it's likely to be
so which one was it and you know if you
push the right one maybe you got a Nobel
Prize what's the wrong one hmm do they
call back and I was very lucky you ball
you hit the right that's a lot of luck
to get a Nobel Prize absolutely well a
lot of hard work - we'll talk about that
in a moment
medicine and physiology prize you are
one of the winners Thomas Souter I think
they were driving somewhere I had flown
from San Francisco to Spain the night
before I had arrived early morning and
midlet went to the car was trying to
find a somewhat obscure little city
beautiful city code by ISA wasn't happy
because I couldn't find that place
phone rings I thought it was my
colleague widely assumed I was lost I
wasn't actually even a Swedish accent
because they never reached me it was
Adam Smith who's the Buddha shacks
the British hasn't British accent who
works for noble media and who thought I
knew which I didn't and as it was out my
leaf corded phone call sort of documents
documents my at least you've got the
news in deepest pain and professor
Robert Shiller one of the economics
laureates and a sound too intimate but
you're in the bathroom weren't you I was
preparing to leave for a conference in
Phoenix Arizona and I was stepping out
of the shower and the phone rang and I
thought maybe I just let it ring because
it's too difficult to get to the phone
but then I thought about the actually
thought about the Nobel Prize and I
thought well here's a chance and I was
pleasantly surprised very happy moment
and your fellow laureate for economics
Eugene farmer you're famous in early
riser and the students here will be very
impressed to hear that you were doing
what I was listening to Don Pasquale in
doing my back exercises to prepare my
class after that so and I didn't come to
you Michael Levitt sir but do tell us
some what you were doing when you also
embed one of the chemistry laureates of
course in California it was 2:16 I had
gone to sleep an hour before so I was
pretty much asleep what was interesting
about the call it's not just the Swedish
accent there's a lot of I guess trick
calls people call you on that day at
that time and say you've just won the
Nobel Prize and last year apparently
this had happened to somebody of the
night before so this time they actually
ask you a question they tell you things
that only they could know like we got
drunk in Italy in any case as soon as I
heard the news I ran and before I even
updated my facebook entry I quote my
mother you want to call your mother and
I have to mention actually I hope she
won't mind my saying Gertrude Leavitt at
98 you have traveled here to Sweden to
join the celebrations with your son
professor Leavitt can we I think she
deserves
it's wonderful now I want to ask you
some questions let's start with the
economic sir laureates professor Shiller
and professor farmer for those of us
trying to understand how that last
financial crisis happened and are
worried about the next one just give us
an overview how far does your research
help us do that professor Shiller well
you're coming into a big disagreement
most glorious agree and worst thing you
you've home right in and then we're at
gene and I disagree
now I actually predicted the crisis in a
second addition to my book I believe
that smart people can partially predict
the market and why shouldn't they I
think it's it takes like anything else
but you have to remember that you're
predicting human behavior it involves a
kind of broad judgment of bubbles
speculative behavior and people okay I
should say professor for I mean I should
just remind people broadly speaking
along with that Lars Peter Hansen who
sadly could not be with us because he's
not well you were awarded the prize
jointly for launching her a revolution
in thinking to show that prices are very
hard to predict in the short term and
even harder in the long term so
professor farmer what's your answer the
questions can economists help us predict
and avoid financial that's true above
use the right words I believe that's the
state of it but I've looked at the
record systematically in Terry to test
for it you cannot find it in the traces
of the data so that's where we disagree
so what we away on evidence about
statistical evidence about
predictability there's a difference in
perspective now I'm married to a
psychologist and maybe that's part of
the reason he always blames his wife
I believe in the unity of knowledge and
I think there are so many things outside
of economics that people have to wait
psychology sociology anthropology
political science and now we're getting
new thing neuroses on theology well well
yeah these what separates us is an
interpretation of human nature and about
the importance of the individual and the
state things that are and you that's why
although I think we are both scientists
and agree on some facts it's the
interpretation that different gene fama
is one of the most successful stock
market predictors in the world
misinterpreted he has dimensional fund
advisers which is can I say that
managing three hundred and fifty billion
dollars huge fund
why is he so why do these people come to
him because he can predict the market
not perfectly but well enough to
outperform many other who knows how to
predict the market he just won't admit
out of predicting as it were my students
prices and they've been kind enough
wasn't me and what this company does is
it it forms portfolios they concentrate
on particular kinds of risks so it's
well understood that stocks are riskier
than bonds so fight for more portfolio
of stocks I can predict it in the long
term that will output likely outperform
bonds in that sense the market is
predictable that's what he's saying
ok but I don't think you can you can
predict whether the stock market is
going to do something but that's a
different story
I mean there's a live debate here about
economic students particular in the UK
we've got this debate wanting to be
engaged in policy debates we have one
professor of economics at London
University who said you know my students
are flipping the pages
best sellers in economics because they
want to get involved in policy debates
they're not happy with what they're
getting in class because they feel
they're no better equipped to interpret
what's going on than students of
archaeology for instance do you believe
it is your role as professors of
economics to teach your undergraduates
in your post graduates how to better
understand the world of finance in that
weird real world oriented and Jean
although he's you wouldn't know it
listening to him he's had a huge impact
on the way finances practice and it's
very helpful he's done a lot very
generous isn't to your fellow laureate
is often that you get to laureates
you've been awarded the prize but a
different interpretation and yet one is
silver and gems like that in in his
comments students I want to ask you I
know you want students of science but
does any of this resonate with you in
terms of the kind of lessons that you're
getting from your professors do you feel
that it equips you to understand what's
going on in the world in your own
particular disciplines any comments fees
in the students yes I think there's a
comment here as a physicist and a
graduate student we are taught to
analyze data in a real-world environment
at famous experiments and around the
world like the Large Hadron Collider in
Geneva so I definitely think that our
our schooling our education applies to
large a big world pictures for sure
okay another comments on this point I
think there's a lady here I am NOT a
economics in economics either I'm a
neuroscientist but we're taught to
problem-solve and think critically and
that should help in solving many
problems that were faced with thank you
I think there's one more just yeah yeah
I'm also a science student and I really
think I've learned in the last year on
my mastery or indicators really tries us
to think critically and understand the
world but you also understand after five
years that is really complex okay thank
you well then I think that kind of sets
the scene a little bit for us to move
into the
into the scientists and there's an
underlying theme here do you should you
a scientist teach the kind of science
that will help us address you know the
big problems of the day Jim Rothman by
equipping students with the skills of
rigorous analytical thinking of taking a
problem breaking it down to component
parts asking which parts are solvable
which ones can't be solved today and
then directing your effort appropriately
that way of thinking can be is the basis
for solving problems of any kind whether
they're of immediate import or that
whether they're problems we don't even
know about today what you're saying is
as you said in your speech when you
receive a Nobel Prize it's
curiosity-driven research it's not
research that's driven towards solving a
specific problem it's basic you can
never predict and I think we all agree
on the sequin almost never predict where
something will lead in all of our work
there are examples of basic science that
we've achieved in our laboratory and our
theoretical work that have applications
that one couldn't have imagined and in
my own work what I did was a very basic
problem in how proteins are transported
in yeast cells which turns out having
application in liver cancer in ways that
I couldn't have imagined I mean your
research for medicine and physiology
helps us with our knowledge of a huge
range of illnesses diabetes brain
disorders but I should also say Botox
I mean Botox obviously has a magical
purpose because it helps people with
paralysis as I said in my remarks last
night my colleagues Rothman and SubPop
figured out how nerve cells communicate
with one another it turns out that
botulism the disease works by producing
a toxin that inactivates protein
molecules that they worked on and that
has applications in a lot of things
cosmetic or or neuromuscular talks
yourself no I have not used it myself
but I don't think I need it just yet
yeah
dito professor shaikh i think we want to
go to one of our students here a
question about physics yes I am from the
Royal Institute of Technology and I was
wondering what do you think or what
kinds of technological applications do
you think will come from the discovery
of the Higgs boson let's go to processor
professor Peter Higgs yes III don't know
of any applications you're asking about
how you would make use of of something
which has been discovered which you have
to put you have to put a lot of energy
into the making of it and then it lasts
for an extremely short time how how can
you do do anything useful with with that
it's true it's true that particles which
have been discovered previously some of
them have applications in medicine for
example but they're relatively
long-lived particles by our person
standards the things which even when
they're at rest maybe lasts about a
microsecond and if you if you make them
move fast and relativity tells you they
last longer and you can make beams and
you can use them in in cancer therapy
and that sort of thing well that that's
okay for that kind of particle but but
when you're exploring this extremely
high energy range where the things you
produce just don't last very long it's
hard to see how you could actually
control them and use them okay you
shared the prize with with professor
Higgs for the physics for the theory
that explains why the tiny particles
that make up atoms have mass I want to
be frank with you I want to ask you the
student there mentioned the fact that
it's called the Higgs boson theory
everybody says including professor Higgs
that it should more accurately be known
as the beh particle the Robert Brout who
is unfortunately was not able to receive
the prize because
he died but it should be known as the
Higgs particle first introduced although
I but even sunny things involved right
the the contribution of English is
important in the sense but so and they
have another things right they detect
the particle yes that one sentence
things on their detection and I think
there have been many people which has
played the whole before the seal he was
made and people who have made things
after the theories made and as usual
this is complete nonsense to give the
name of a person
any person I think it's reasonable to
give as for all the particles a letter
and personally what do you think and
then that final suggestion take your
name off Higgs boson and just call it
the letter H H very anyway your response
I would be very happy with that solution
because the person's situation
embarrasses me
III think why does it embarrass you well
because it's it's it's come about so
accidentally it's not not a recognition
of that I I was any sort of special
person in this is story there were there
were many people involved as France wise
has said and it's it's it's it's so
happened that my name has been attached
to it for a number of accidental reasons
and that's unfair to the other people
involved I'd like to make a distinction
between the particle and what's called
the mechanism which is how to how to get
mass for other particles I'm happy with
the solution which is now becoming
common in the particle physics world to
call it the beh mechanism and that's to
me the really the important part of the
theory they the particle itself should
not carry anybody's name and the
solution of giving it the letter H
because in the past my name has been
attached to it is is a good one we'll
leave that particular exchange there and
the student next time you ask you a
question
be careful what you call Thomas to talk
you you are one of the joint winners of
the medicine physiology prize I just
want to ask you what you think about the
of your particular theories does it
matter to you that your discoveries for
your work on vesicles and I won't go
into too much but they kind of are act
as the cells internal shipping service
or postman they can send materials
around the cell or can even fuse with
its outer surface but how important was
it for you when you were doing your
research that this would actually help
perhaps save lives very I was afraid you
were going to ask me about the Higgs
bosons I think you know common theme and
in science is we do science best when we
don't have an application in mind
because it limits our imagination and
creativity but in the end we feel most
rewarded when what we discover out of a
quest for knowledge leads actually to an
application and so in it what I do and I
think what my fellow laureates do I
think it's extremely important for us to
find that I wouldn't call it an accident
but serendipity what we knew actually is
useful is it it is it a motivating
factor for all of you in your research
or do you just see it as a bonus and to
use an economic simile here is that
research that is longer-term is like
leaven much much larger payoff and in
some senses I think that this sort of
fits into what mr. Chapman was saying
you don't just think about solving
tomorrow's problems today you want to
solve think about problems that have you
even been designed yet and then you'll
have a massive impact and I think this
is a very critical thing because we
increasingly want you to solve
short-term problems and I think it is
perhaps high energy physics doesn't have
a very direct practical application but
it's really hard to imagine the
applications that are going to come up
for example yeah the long views I mean
these general recognized decades later
from the work they actually did I mean
James Rothman just picking up this point
about research in the long view and
so on I mean would you be happy for
you're a young scientist starting out
today trying to embark on some research
which needed funding well I'd be very
happy if I was a young scientist doesn't
I wouldn't be an old science you know I
think we're in a very challenging Yerba
for the very reasons that we we heard a
moment ago from from Michael there's an
increasingly increasing effort on the
short-term short-term success and it
causes young scientists to take less in
the way of risk and to do more research
that's more incremental as small step
here a small step they're more likely to
reap a short-term reward but those of us
around the table today I think each in
our own way we're taking on problems
that we're very challenging in our time
quite some time ago we all feel an
enormous increase in pressure from
public institutions or rather from
politicians and the public foundations
patient advocates whatever to do science
that will lead to tangible results
tomorrow cure this cure that now and in
my view that never works because you
can't cure something you don't
understand in our case Physiology or
medicine some of us try to solve
problems which are really difficult like
how enzyme work in their case what is
the mass in the universe and eventually
some of the solutions have application
in a really to your question what is
missing in all of this is teaching
politicians in the university people who
will become politician to understand
some concepts in science so in the
future they will be able to do better
decision making this is this is
something important that we all should
be better educated in science by
examination we should it seems to me
that I don't know if this is necessary
because I gue require a very
narrow-minded politician to say that
size hadn't had a massive effect on
everything we do over the last hundred
years it seems to me that the general
you know maybe none targeted investment
in science that we've had say let's just
say since the Second World War has paid
off unbelievably the living standard you
know maybe that's why we have so many
people on earth but it's all part of the
success of science so it seems to me
that we don't have to justify every
point that professor washer made about
my suppose you're basically saying
scientific illiteracy that people need
to be better educated public politicians
I mean is scientific illiteracy more
acceptable than other forms of
illiteracy I have thought about that a
lot if I said I will Shakespeare who
cares about him you don't think my god
but if somebody says a billion a million
what difference does it make you know
that's a pretty big error people lead
need to learn much more statistically no
I think there's a tremendous ignorance
of science in the u.s. which
unfortunately is fostered by the
political process right now we have a
great deal of disbelief in basic
scientific principles in the United
States that drives the politics there's
a dismissal of evolution there's a
disbelief and climate change in spite of
the overwhelming evidence so we have to
do a better job it used to be that the
government you know I've been the
beneficiary of this we have all been the
beneficiary of an investment in science
starting with the end of World War two
and Sputnik error in the United States
there was enormous investment in science
science education that's diminished
particularly in the public realm it's
not happening now you don't think
science is getting the funding
sufficiently
not enough and and and then what is
funded is being managed more much more
so than it used to be scientific
research provides a public good that
benefits the entire world so one country
let's take Sweden politicians here would
rationally think why should we pay for
it
the rest of the world will do it anyway
if we pay a million kronor for some
research project only a tiny part of
that will benefit Sweden it'll go all
over the world so part of the defense of
scientific research has to be a
cosmopolitan public spirit at all so
shouldn't it be
what Professor suit have said which is
that you scientists have to communicate
better with the public and politicians
about what it is you are doing we have a
question I think from one of the
students here about this subject yeah
Ricard agree the Karolinska Institute so
I wonder if you think that those
scientists communicate badly their
science how do we avoid the
misunderstanding and gain a better
presence on public debates on this point
of communication professor Farmer
economist obviously is not a pure
science your social scientists but you
are asked to comment every hour every
day of the week because of the financial
crisis and so on do you think you make a
good job of communicating with the
public I don't think we make it clear
and distinguishing between the things we
know based on research that have been
done and opinions that we have based on
our own interpretation of things I don't
think we do a good job on that I think
too many economists are willing to talk
too much about things that they really
don't know a lot about I try to avoid
that I'm not sure I'm exactly successful
some media interviews yourself wants to
predict what's going on no actually
before he got the Nobel Prize nobody was
much interested in me and afterward they
could became interested and I said I
didn't change I'm still that dumb guy
you thought I was professor Shindo you
do interact a lot with the Putman you've
written books which are suppose to be
accepted at the students
you write books which is supposed to be
accessible to even people who haven't
studied economics what's your view on
how economists communicate with the
public
well I think that economists have been
too much in the science model of writing
concise short I mean there's some of
that is good concise short journal
articles that make a very narrow but
frontier contribution that's we model
ourselves after physics particularly I
think but I think there's an older a
different tradition that could also
valuable and that is writing books that
draw together theory and practice and
the profession tends to
the if you say I've written a book that
is rare they think oh that's a they call
it a popularization but I don't think
that some of these books that are widely
read are popularization at all they're
their synthesis that can operate at a in
the level of an ordinary intelligent
lectures online as well you provide
lectures yeah you can take my car online
yeah there you are and professor Leavitt
you also provide lectures online 50
years
communication is undergone an incredible
revolution and at the time when you know
Facebook is being phased out for Twitter
which has been phased out for snapshot
or whatever it seems to me that the only
way we can communicate and the key thing
is not to communicate with people in
their 40s even if the rate is to
communicate with people in their teens
and early twenties it seems to me that
everyone here should be on Facebook and
I am are your nephews online are they
accessible to open on students as soon
as ever or not of signs all right let's
just get some feedback here who thinks
that scientists do a good job of
communicating with the public and I see
people put their hands up who thinks
does scientists do a good job of
communicating with the public do you
think scientists do a bad job of
communicating with the public who thinks
that these Nobel laureates have been
doing a good job of communicating it so
no you got a good you got a good
response there I just asked you whether
you feel that sometimes scientists are
running ahead of what society both
understands and thinks is acceptable and
without going into various examples here
it's really a question about the
potential misuse of your discoveries or
a potential lack of understanding of
what your discoveries may bring about I
mean there are so many examples I'm
think of the belgian geneticist who
brought about GM who says that
professor Montagu Marc van Montagu who
says that society fears science because
it upsets the traditional way of living
do any of you worry at night about how
your various discoveries
misused in the future I think to turn
the question just a bit I think there is
an over selling on our part sometimes of
what science can do and just use an
example the war on cancer in the 1970s
under President Nixon really really
wasn't it wasn't an enormous of
investment a lot of science was done but
cancer was not cured we shouldn't over
promise what we can deliver is there
ever hype professor suit off on the part
of scientists absolutely I think that in
communicating with the public that's
probably one of the biggest mistakes we
as scientists have made because we
haven't communicated the magnitude of
the challenge we haven't communicated
how difficult it is for example to
understand the cancer cell or to
understand the brain and people expect
us to solve this and to have solutions
tomorrow and that's our fault why do you
think that happens because we claim to
make discoveries as a community that
aren't there do you think your ask their
own questions sometimes or pushed into
saying things you shouldn't say by
there's no doubt about that
yes it's Lamy the media again yes I
think one of the difficulty the
communication of science is the basic
education to begin with after all you
see in a sense maybe you can try to give
a vague idea to the people about how
they can be cured about some cancer and
they may understand something right but
if you try to explain something which is
deep
I don't want to make basic right which
is simply the thing they don't have any
mathematical basis to understand this
and the difficulty comes already from
the first you know I said at the start
that you are all gentlemen obviously
Alice Munro won the prize for literature
and one of the chemistry laureates
margin carp last can't be with us but
obviously another man what is it about
science women Randy Schekman Michael
love it
I think the problem is with the age
group of the gentlemen here we all did
our work I mean the work that I was
credited for I did as an assistant
professor that was back at a time when
there were few women in fact there were
no women in my department there are many
more women that we hire now so I look
forward to in 30 years you'll still be
just as young interviewing a number of
women I like you and still no Botox
professor Higgs lack of women well in my
kind of physics through there are
interesting differences between
different countries at least at least
within Europe and until I went to Italy
I think my prejudice would have been
that the the southern Catholic countries
were less likely to have women
scientists than the northern mostly
Protestant countries because of the
attitudes of the Catholic Church to what
women ought to be doing it isn't so it's
the other way around
it's it's Italy which has the largest
proportion of women in in physics and
the the northern countries do rather
badly by comparison that's a very
interesting point you raise there
professor Higgs because Sweden which is
famous for its very efficient and
effective childcare system actually has
a very low number of professors right
across the board not only in science
it's only about 21% since we have some
students from here at universities in
Sweden and what do you think about this
gender issue I would like to comment on
what Professor Higgs said that religion
has some impact on this and I think in
the earlier generation you had
nowadays we can look at this room it's
full of women we are gaining power and
we are starting to do
but we still have to take a lot of risks
and to do a lot of difficult choices for
example I had to move from my country
because the maternities and and those
problems in my country are still
problematic that's why I moved to a
northern country which country from
Portugal is okay
another person another science student
I'm in social sciences which is for
women and in the Social Work which is
even more women and still in Sweden we
have men that are on the top of the the
top positions in both society and
science so that must reflect something
even when there's basically all women in
the field usually what you do you have
kids as a male and the female and except
for pregnancy which usually people are
only weighed maybe for a few weeks the
kids is something you get together say
if it's a female problem it should also
be a male problem
let's have another student yes I see
somebody there PhD student and molecular
biology there are a lot of women in
science now as someone else's pointed
out and I don't think that there are
less opportunities for women in science
I think that if you want to have a
family on a career that's your choice
and I think that there are many examples
of successful women science scientists
who have made it happen
maybe not sitting at the table today but
may be able to stand table in the future
and I I think that the future will
reflect that but I think that the
opportunities are there professor Randy
Schekman
you're not only concerned about
encouraging women to study science you
want to ensure that everyone from all
walks of life I'm very I'm very
concerned about public higher education
that may not be as much an issue in
Sweden but in the United States the
individual states have decreased their
support of public higher education
particularly there's virtually an
inverse relationship between the funding
of prisons in the United States and the
funding of public higher education and I
think this has been much to the
detriment of the middle class who
wouldn't necessarily have that in large
numbers have access to the elite
institutions that are represented around
this table you disappointed very
disappointed and III came from a
middle-class family I could work a
summer job and pay for the whole year
room board books that is no longer
possible that's I think that is a that
is has damaged access to to the the
highest reaches of science at least in
the United States anybody else on this
issue of access and in the UK professor
thinks we have a similar debate similar
situation where we're I mean my
generation had a lot of public funding
for going to universities and and
there's a generation of of academics not
just in science but other fields who
came from all kinds of social
backgrounds but now it's been made much
more difficult by the present policies
policies of introducing fee
and people from poor backgrounds are
simply deterred from trying are you
worried that actually that this crisis
in funding in some countries is going to
jeopardize their future as being centers
of excellence where you can get the kind
of people like you who come up with
discoveries I mean just think about the
fact that as far as I understand
sociological studies suggest that social
mobility in the United States is now
lower than Europe and that sort of puts
it on so we always used to be that
social mobility look at me I mean in the
United States was better than in Europe
and now it's the opposite is gonna move
back to you moved back to Europe moving
away from the United States see not
black and white you know but integrated
way we comes back to research support it
comes down to public education it comes
down to a value system of immediacy
versus a longer-term view and why is it
going to well I think in part it's a lot
a lot of it has gone already to Europe
Europe had a tremendous task of
rebuilding after World War two that's
largely done in the sciences especially
China China you know in Asia are very
hungry to to be major players but they
tend to be still quite short-term
focused the China thinks in five-year
plans
it's a 50-year plan if it's a play any
kind of a plan at all it's more like an
intent and you think there are certain
cultures that better encourage free
thinking the blue skies thinking that
brings about the great discoveries I was
thinking that the United States had a
more public spirit after World War two
than it does now the the Marshall Plan
is an example of something that happened
then that was an aid program to Europe
it wouldn't happen now and that the the
declining support for education is
another example of that I wanted to
remind us that we are here at the legacy
of Alfred Nobel who
tremendous public spirit and that's one
reason why the Nobel Prize is a renewed
inspiration talking about access you now
have access to the ear of the powerful
in the world are you going to be using
this newfound recognition that you have
to put forward the case that you'd be
making about greater access or any other
issue I'll come to you professor love it
I think it's really important to have an
issue after getting the Nobel Prize you
have to do something with the rest of
your life and besides science I'll that
I'll continue to do I think an issue for
me that is really really worrying is
that the there used to be people who had
positions between the ages of 20 and 40
and that whole generation is slowly
disappearing it's becoming very hard
become an independent scientist if
you're younger than 40 and you know 30
or 40 years ago you could be in your
early 20s I think that this is it can be
explained in many ways sociologically
but I think that it it's as if you have
another 20 University here instead of
getting a position in five years it can
take 15 years and I think this is a huge
waste of talent because we see talent
young talent bringing up things like
Facebook I'm gonna say that you know you
have to drop out of a college even you
know to have found Microsoft Apple
Google Facebook Yahoo not a good sign
it's a general Society social ethical
problem an economic problem that thinks
more and more reducing the possibility
of funding students to help them to go
to these situations the good in
Benjamin's but it's very difficult
otherwise very briefly
anybody got any big idea about how
they're going to be using the new
influence there's a Nobel laureate to in
some way better the world not only as a
scientist but beyond the realm of
science professor Walsh or do you have
your hand up I will find it out
eventually
professor farmer I'm gonna continue to
do what I've been doing but my my simple
attitude is everything that creates
economic output
to humanity my plumber is perhaps as
important as I am I wish I had a good
one but he may not just wouldn't they
not be as important as mine but
everybody that contributes something to
output makes everybody else bigger
better better off so I'm good at what I
do why would I try to do something I'm
not good at good at I think I can make
the world better if I continue what I'm
doing
Eugene fama thank you very much indeed
and gentlemen thank you all very much
well that brings this exclusive program
to an end we've heard what this year's
Nobel laureates have to say about the
role of science and economics in today's
society we've also heard from the
students here from Sweden about what
they think the road of science should
also be who knows there may be a future
Nobel Prize winner amongst you all thank
you to the family and friends of the
laureates to the laureates themselves of
course to you wherever you are for
watching this programme from me Zainab
Adar we here in the concert hall in
Stockholm goodbye
you